welcome back southern nevada continues
to come together to honor
fallen hero trooper micah may he lost
his life this week
he had been fighting to survive at umc
this was after he was hit by a car
during a chase on the i-15 this is the
scene from just moments ago
as his body was taken to the coroner's
office from umc
victoria saha has been out there all
afternoon she joins us live
with another look victoria
hey sasha the procession just ended a
few moments ago
as you can see several members of the
nevada highway patrol are here and some
of them
are leaving they had just taken a
trooper may's body inside that's where
he's going to stay
for the night i also noticed what looked
like friends and family of his
coming out of the building it was a
somber day for the nevada highway patrol
up until this moment earlier today at
umc where several members of the nevada
highway patrol
and other law enforcement agencies
gathered at umc as they prepare
to escort trooper may's body his squad
car was also parked in front of the
hospital
it's been four days since trooper may
was struck by an alleged carjacker as he
was laying down spike strips
leaving him in critical condition
trooper may died on thursday the nevada
highway patrol says
they have not left his side since the
incident happened and they're all
grieving the loss of a brother together
leaning on each other it's there's been
a lot of tears a lot of hugs
but at the end of the day it's a big
part of what we do
is we lean on each other and we're all
here to serve our community
trooper may is a father of two and the
injured police officers fund has set up
an account to help trooper may's family
which
trooper smeka says is part of the nhp
family now
on tuesday evening there will be a
candlelight vigil to honor trooper may
at the police memorial park we are told
everyone is invited reporting live
victoria zaha 8 news now